it's just an honor to be here I think
the work that the NEA BPD does is so
critical and you know it's really kudos
to the people involved Perry and all the
people that she works with to support
the public in greater awareness about
BPD and it's also an honor to be on this
panel with people who have been kind of
role models and mentors to me Charlie
was my DBT trainer and John was somebody
I met very early in my research career
and really helped me to kind of
crystallize some thinking about how to
better understand these disorders I do
DBT I do MBT I do GPM I'm very informed
by the work about oh Ken Berg and I do
agree that all these treatments work
very well and patients need treatments
that are tailored to them rather than
having clinicians who are obsessed with
one way of thinking so I want to
continue the vein of thought here and
really think about how mentalization
based treatment offers a lot of similar
components as these other treatments
maybe packaged differently and related
to a different set of concepts and
research but hopefully provides a
different way of thinking about
individuals that might be satisfying and
effective for both the clinicians who
deliver this treatment and the patients
who receive it okay so this is the
agenda for today and I have to say that
trying to summarize the last ten years
of advanced in MBT is a very difficult
task I'll do my best and talk about
updates in theory I think this is one
thing that I really respect about Peter
and Anthony is their kind of unending
effort to incorporate new findings into
the way that they think about how their
treatment works and I'm also going to
present some evidence that's I think
relevant to a lot of these different
treatments on the interpersonal problems
in BPD and the way that people with BPD
represent what goes on in relationships
in their own minds and then behaves
based on those representations and I'm
going to talk about some expansion in
the way that the practice of MVT has
progressed
but I'm gonna start with a little mantra
that I think defines the culture at the
Gundersen residence it's a new serenity
prayer and I do have some jokes they
might not be good ones but I'll try that
and I think it's about having some good
defenses humor a sense of taking
responsibility from oneself and also
acceptance and I think that actually is
incorporated in all three of these
treatments but I put this up here
because I have an apology for you I have
to admit I have a little bit of an
obsessional personality and I've worked
on my slides since they were due so some
of these are not in your slide set but I
do encourage you that I think this is
recorded you can kind of look back at
this and try to reference it and try to
kind of stay with me instead of worry
about what's on the slides they're
really just a device to help you learn
and understand or maybe look at
something instead of listening to me so
I'm going to talk first about theory and
formulation behind this treatment like
John had mentioned this is really a
treatment that is based on some general
broad capacity that we all have to
mentalize and what that means is that we
all have a capacity to understand what's
in our minds driving the things that we
do and also try to imagine what's in the
minds of others when they interact with
us that's as simple as that it took me
like 10 years to maybe boil it down to
something so simple but it's something
that we all do that all treatments
really have to do with but I think the
power of MBT is the way it bridges both
the past to the present it incorporates
basic fundamentals that have been
provided to us by psychoanalytic ideas
about how we just think about things
imagine them conceptualize them
represent them symbolise them with
something more modern that is really hot
in scientific investigation that is
social cognition and theory of mind and
that has to do with appreciating what
goes on in the mental activity of other
people how we model that how
imagine that how we conceptualize that
and how effective we are in that
capacity MBT also has to do with
relationships just like TFP and
fundamentally helps people to improve
their capacity to organize the complex
interaction between self and other not
just on that outside that is the
external behavior but on the inside all
their thoughts feelings beliefs motives
preferences desires that is very
complicated for us all whether or not
you have BPD so in these inter plays
there's the behavioral parts the part
that you can see the part that you can
kind of interpret and there are internal
parts the part that you have to guess
about and there are interactions between
the self and the other that make this
process very dynamic and fast-moving
even more so when you're working with
BPD and it takes the capacity to hold a
lot of things in mind and manipulate
them think about them and react to them
now beyond that there are two
psychological aspects of mentalization
has to do with it's both in the
cognitive realm and in the an affective
realm like John was saying and these
things are fused and MBT is really to do
with helping people integrate these two
parts of their mental activity and as
you can see when it comes to the
cognitive realm there's a number of
different things involved I won't
belabor them they're on the slide and in
the effective realm there's a number of
complex facets and these things really
interact and the goal of MBT is to help
people integrate them so that they can
feel clearly and emotionally know
themselves okay that's different than
just being aware of your emotions it's
different than just being aware of your
thoughts it's about integrating some
felt experience that you can think about
now there's also two modes of
mentalizing that is an implicit mode
that we all do there are automatic
things that we think about the word
completely unaware of when we don't pay
attention to them and these are
assumptions these are things that
constitute like a kind of elephant in
the room and
relationship there are the things we
don't talk about or attend to that can
become explicit that is that we think
about them in psychotherapy or when
we're mindful or when we meditate and we
talk about them and these modes can kind
of evolve and interact and lastly
there's a kind of switching point about
this and this is like a kind of advance
in the understanding about mentalization
it has to do with stress I think John
talked a little bit about this and one
of the questions had to do with this is
that for all of us mentalizing changes
under stress and I kind of joked with
Emily it was in a vulnerable moment of
high stress for me that I completely
lost my mind and agreed to do this I
gave for talks before I came here in the
last two weeks and I have a problem a
target behavior of over a commitment and
I just completely was not thinking when
I said yes I want to do it because
emotionally I love any a BPD I love this
conference I love speaking to families
and consumers and professionals about
BPD but I did not think it was realistic
to devote the time so I had a switch
point okay my prefrontal cortex the part
that can evaluate strategize plan
problem-solve you know it's starting to
mentalize but then it switches over from
stress to like automatic behaviors okay
so like my impulses my emotions will
guide my behaviors instead of the part
of my brain that can evaluate what's
going on both in in my reality and in in
my mind so the thing about this is that
for people who have sensitive stress
systems like people with BPD among other
disorders your ability to mentalize will
rise with stress actually if you don't
have any stress you can't think you know
that's why the the state of withdrawal
for people with BPD is very problematic
you can't organize thoughts when you
don't have enough stimulation but when
you have more stress you actually
mentalize more but it hits a point at
which it becomes counterproductive
you can't think under too much stress
that's all of us but for people with BPD
they're more sensitive to stress and
there's a switch point that might be act
evaded by the activation of attachment
for people with BPD or other for other
people who have very insecure attachment
styles the attachment itself where it's
designed to help people regulate in the
face of stress actually produces more
stress and it causes people to go into
this kind of subcortical mode where your
emotions and impulses and kind of urge
to act really start to dominate your
behavior your behavioral kind of
pathways so you know what happens here
just like I've said psychological
understanding drops and is rapidly
replaced by confusion about what's going
on in one's mind under high arousal I do
not have BPD or so John has not
diagnosed me yet and I I have this
phenomenon under enough stress I can not
think clearly so this is an advanced and
clarification in thinking is that what
were to do in MBT is how people have
more flexibility around how they
mentalize so that it's not so split and
divided or extreme so that the goal is
to differentiate and also understand the
interaction between self and other in
one's life and in psychotherapy so that
you can see what the other person might
be thinking and also reduce your own
sensitivity to the other people state of
mind you know I think BPD has to do with
sensitivity to states above it and it's
about moving from being implicit you
know assumption based and automatic
reflexive and your mentalizing to being
more controlled thoughtful flexible and
evaluating in the current moment it's
also about being able to kind of move
between external cues of what people are
thinking like this person didn't call me
therefore they don't love me that's kind
of external preoccupation to something
internal hmm I wonder what's going on
with this person that caused them to
behave that way and it's about
connecting feelings to thoughts and
overcoming
leading of these two things and that is
again the feeling of feelings okay
so this is just a graphic to help you
see this it kind of goes from being
impression driven to more control
appearance-based to more inference or
imagination from certainty some people
with BPU will say I know this is true
there's nothing you can say that will
convince me otherwise
and this goes to Dowe and from emotional
contagion to some independence and
understanding what is going on in
oneself and others so now that I've told
you the basics of mentalization I'm
going to talk about the basis
theoretically
and when MBT was first developed it was
really founded in attachment theory and
attachment research which really joins
kind of traditional psychoanalytic thing
and thinking with some empirical basis
so like John said I'm going to just
basically talk about the basics of
attachment theory there is like a kind
of call in serious I think I've done
that's on any a BPD website if you want
more detail about this but just to boil
it down attachment is a basic
instinctual response we all have and we
all have behaviors when we're young to
bid for attachment babies cry they have
to stress in a variety of ways they are
cute
thank God they're cute it's like a
survival element and attachment gets
activated when a person or a child is
distressed it's not every relationship
is not an attachment relationship it's
those relationships you rely on under
stress that are attachment relationships
and what you get from attachment can be
disturbed when there's problems early on
okay so you can get the problem of
insecurity in multiple domains like John
was saying it's not just about specific
symptoms its domains of dysfunction so
insecurity and attachment will be
associated with inability to regulate
contain
modulate effect that's how attachment is
relation related to emotional
dysregulation it also disturbs what we
call the secure base the secure base is
that confidence to explore the world and
encounter risk and know that you're
gonna be okay because of the
relationships you have in your life and
it also disturbs the future ability to
develop and maintain meaningful
relationships and I'm going to talk
about some advances in research that
help us understand more specifically
what goes wrong and relationships in
people who have BPD I'm just going to
and this is all kind of explain more in
detail in that Collins series so please
look at it so the relationship between
attachment and mentalization is this is
that when you have a secure attachment
you can think more you're less scared
you're more regulated you're less alone
that happens for all of us not just for
people with BPD and when you mentalize
better guess what your attachments work
better right when you can understand
what's going on with the person you need
and communicate effectively with them
and collaborate then you're going to
actually enhance that attachment so this
goes back and forth and more
specifically what happens
developmentally is this is the top the
pointer yeah okay so you start with the
child in this state of arousal when
you're a baby you don't know what's
wrong with you you just cry and you hope
someone will figure it out
it's a nonverbal expression and the job
of the caregiver is to mirror back in a
reasonably contingent that means like a
kind of resonant way but in a
metabolized way a marked way so that's a
reprint a ssin of what the caregiver
thinks is going on in the child's mind
and that expression or representation
helps people to develop a psychological
understanding of themselves this binds
with that kind of felt experience okay
so that joins psychological thought with
experiential
data so what happens in BPD is very
complicated because it's not that people
with BPD you don't get attached the
problem is they get too attached
and that creates too much stress for the
mentalizing system so when I first
started this there was a lot of really
interesting research that confirmed that
insecure attachment is associated with
BPD there are over 20 studies there
summarized in these papers and in
particular there's a kind of uneasy fit
between a clingy attachment style
preoccupation with a fearful one so
clinging is okay you don't you're not
going to necessarily have problems if
you're clingy and being a little
mistrustful is okay in itself but when
you have both you both really need
people and you don't trust them that's a
problem okay and that is something
that's relevant to BPD but in my own
study that we use the data from the
larger family study the personality that
we did at McLean we found that people
with major depression also have a higher
risk of this attachment style but at a
lesser severity than people with BPD so
what happens is interactional when there
are attachment problems I think there's
too much of a kind of reflexive impulse
to blame the parents that's that's
really an incomplete understanding of
the problem there's an interaction
between a vulnerable person and their
caregiver that drives an interactional
process I think that's what's so
important about attachment it's a system
so if you start with a child who makes
an attachment bid that's clingy angry
passive or helpless and oscillatory it's
confusing it's oftentimes detached from
what they're really feeling it's
conflicted it sends mixed messages and
sometimes it's controlling so what
happens for the caregiver is this they
get over-involved they get
overprotective they get inconsistent
because they have to put so much energy
into managing
attachment and then they burn out or
they give up or they feel ineffective
and they sometimes will also get roped
and into intense effective states where
they respond to the child in either
frightening or frightened ways so when
your child tries to commit suicide
you're going to be frightened and that's
going to get communicated in the
interaction and that is what completes
that attachment transaction is the
interaction between the two that is
their emotional responses their
behavioral responses and how it is they
understand each other so what happens is
when your patient or child or friend or
partner with BPD is in the bottom not
just a child but a person in a
constitutional state of arousal that
they don't understand they can't
represent in their mind they send these
extreme signals suicide self sabotage
self harm reckless behavior to a
caregiver they can't put aside their own
emotional reaction so it's no longer
representing what they think is going on
with the child it's representing an
amplified form of a negative emotion
okay so you can see how that contributes
to problems and mentalization it's a
systems problem it's not just on the end
of the person with BPD or their parents
it's interactive so this is what happens
in families which I do a lot of family
work it's one of my favorite things like
John is saying about couples it's far
more interesting fast paced and it is
really important to the work of helping
people with BPD get better so say you
have family member one there in high
emotion and they don't mentalize well
none of us do it in high emotion and
then they make efforts instead of to
cope or relate they make efforts to
control or change themselves or others
so oftentimes when the patient's at the
GRE we we talk about how they're trying
to control the situation rather than
cope with it like perfectionism that's a
perfect example of trying to control the
thing that you're going to have a lot of
emotion about rather than cope with the
possible emotion you're gonna have about
it and what happens then is controlling
behavior sorry about this and then
there's a family member who cares about
this person that with this cycle it
affects high emotion in that person and
that engenders poor mentalizing and then
they make efforts to control themselves
in others and these things interact so
you can see how this gets really hyper
activated very quickly now this happens
in therapy too which is the problem of
trying to use non personality focused
treatments for people with personality
problems yes we need generalist
approaches but they have to be informed
by an understanding of dysfunction in
personality functioning rather than just
a kind of treatment for depression or a
treatment for bipolar disorder has to
really focus on the problems and
sensitivities of a person with BPD or
other PDS and so what happens in a
treatment is the same process where a
patient will have an emotional challenge
they have mild in to stress and anxiety
and then they activate their attachment
which is necessarily going to be hyper
aroused conflicted disorganized
problematic and this causes even more
interaction that causes more problems
for both the therapist and the patient
so that's the problem of treatment with
BPD and then the bio behavioral switch
gets kind of put into this kind of
automatic process much earlier than for
people without these attachment problems
so that your access to thinking
representing conceptualizing am at
managing and imagining being flexible
about different points of view goes
offline
you're too challenged by the
interpersonal contact so what happens
here is a failure of mental ization and
at first this was kind of conceptualized
in more like kind of simplified and
maybe exclusive ways and what Bateman
and fauna ghee said is that there's
temporary failures of mentalizing
because people with BPD are actually
really good at mentalizing in some
situations it's not across all contexts
in specific situations where under
hyperactivated attachment or intense
effect they'll either go into a detached
mode and this is where people with BPD
might be the best patient you ever had
they're smart they're psychological they
absorb the information very well but it
might be completely dissociated and
disconnected from what they actually
feel or what's going on in their life
that's a problem of pretend mode pseudo
mentalization and it's a failure to
integrate they're not trying to pull the
wool over your eyes
then there's psychic equivalence where
they will tend to believe what is in
their mind is reality I'm bad I can't do
anything right there's no nothing's
going to change that
that psychic equivalence and then Thalia
logic mode which is the need to have
external proof for internal states so
you must drop everything and get on a
plane to show me that I matter to you
you must extend the sessions to show me
that you care I must cut myself to show
you I'm in pain okay and this leads to
the problems of BPD so you can read this
because I have too many slides to go
over and what I want to say is that this
leads to all the domains of
symptomatology and BPD in the nbg theory
and that what they've updated is this
and I'll show you some literature on
this there's also a fourth kind of
concept is that people with BPD hyper
mental eyes that is that they they
actually have these really elaborate
complicated assumptions about what's
going on with other people it's like
they have a dysregulation of mentalizing
and this also feeds into the problem
I'll talk more about that okay so
basically the kind of strengths of MPT
is that it it combines all these ideas
that come from attachment into a
treatment the drive for relationships
for comfort emotional regulation and
secure base is at the bottom of this
treatment the technique is not just MBT
it's that you use the relationship to
help the person to survive stress
there's a real relationship
in the here-and-now it's not about the
past it's about the here and now in the
interactions in one's life and in the
treatment itself and the attachment
security that can be attained in the
treatment whether you're doing DBT NBT
TFP steps whatever it is the attachment
security will allow your patient to
explore their minds and try to do
something that's productive for
themselves or else they have too much
fear self-doubt pain to be able to
manage them so you try to stabilize and
encourage mentalizing through stress in
this treatment and through these
hyperactivated attachment states and
re-establish something that is a piece
of progress in mental ization based
treatment thinking that is reestablish
epistemic trust and collaboration and
I'll show you some data on what that
exactly means so this is a revision to
MBT that I think is both elegant and
complicated now what we've learned about
attachment since that research came out
is that attachment is a nonspecific
factor that confers risk for developing
a lot of psychiatric problems attachment
is something that people use to modulate
a stressful situation when I'm stressed
I rely on my partner my friends my
colleagues my research assistant to help
me survive ok but that is something that
when it's not there I might get
depressed
I might get anxiety I might get
interpersonal problems I might get
dysregulated emotion there's a lot of
outcomes that come from insecure
attachment an insecure attachment is
associated with a number of disorders on
both what was previously called axis one
and two now trust and social learning is
a more specific issue that probably also
relates to number of different disorders
but there's new evidence that shows that
the locus of the problem is here for
people who have BPD and John alluded to
this too is that there's these
interpersonal sensitivities that people
with BPD seem to
really be defined by that the
interpersonal dysfunction instability is
really differentiating and at the at the
center of some of the other
symptomatology
but these factors probably also
increased risk for a number of disorders
that tend to be comorbid with BPD
explaining why people with BPD tend to
have other disorders this is a review
that was done by Brooks Kings Casaus and
a colleague of his that really reviews
the kinds of social cognitive problems
that seem to be that the basis of a
number of disorders but what you see
here is that what he has discovered with
fauna ghee and some other colleagues is
that the problem in BPD is just trust
now we have a lot of new tools that are
enhanced to try to help us understand
the behavioral functioning of a person
in a socially stressful situation that
models their social functioning in a
laboratory where you can measure things
like brain functioning okay and what
we've really started to employ our
number of like kind of behavioral
economic models where the the subjects
have to interact with other subjects and
make decisions on the fly and why this
is an improvement is a lot of people
whether you have a disorder or not don't
know themselves very well and when we
tried to get people to rate their own
mental ization who had BPD people who
had poor mentalizing
rated themselves very high because they
they don't know if they're meant to
happy thing
so self-report is very inadequate for a
lot of different things that people try
to measure so you have to build models
that really test a kind of more
procedural active behavioral component
of what you're trying to measure so a
groundbreaking study was done by Kings
Casaus and his colleagues that was
published in science I include I
encourage you to read the paper I had to
read it like maybe 10 to 20 times to
understand it but basically I was try to
boil it down to you it's a very elegant
study that is a multi round economic
exchange where there's healthy
and healthy control subjects and BPD
subjects that are put in the position of
interacting with an investor so it's
that you give money you receive money
and you make decisions about what you're
gonna do and inherent in that
interaction is the modeling of
understanding what the other person is
gonna do and some trust okay so what
this study showed is that people with
BPD have an incapacity to maintain
cooperation and when there is a problem
that happens in the interaction their
ability to repair it is really impacted
and this is related to differential
brain functioning an area of the brain
that has to do with emotional and social
processing and the conclusion that came
from this is that people with BPD may
have atypical social norms and are
lacking ability to imagine and decide
about a partner's trustworthiness okay
so how this happens is this this is the
breakdown so what happens is that there
are a group of people that are playing a
healthy trustee with a healthy investor
and the investor takes 20 dollars and
repays the trustee $60 and now that you
have to reinvest and there's also a
group with healthy investor and a person
with BPD and what you see here is
striking but in the healthy control
group the percentage invested is you
know pretty similar there's no
significant different difference between
early and late in the interaction and
healthy groups but in BPD something
breaks down over time the level of
investment at the end drops
significantly because there's some
rupture that can't be repaired in the
interaction and what happens is this
thing called coaxing once there's a kind
of disappointment like the investor
doesn't send very much to the trustee
the the trustee and the investor have to
interact in a way that tries to
encourage the other person to
collaborate again and healthy people
this happens a lot more and the payoff
over time is high this is the percentage
of coaxing and healthy investor
versus those with BPD who will just keep
not interacting or not trying to
encourage the other person to get back
into the game with them and this is even
more interesting when you look at the
insula activity which has to do with
emotional processing also sensing things
within the body and it has something to
do with empathy it's implicated and
maternal and romantic love what happens
is that when there's a low level
investment it's very active and there's
a very linear clear response with the
level of investment for people who have
BPD there's no kind of rhyme or reason
to what activity goes on in this part of
the brain based on what's happening in
reality what's happening in their
interaction and sometimes when you're
interacting with a person with the
vulnerabilities of BPD sometimes you're
left with what Wow why in the world are
they thinking that or what in the world
are they thinking and they may be
responding to something offline it's
deep in their brain their emotions their
memories things that have nothing to do
with it the current interaction and so
when you actually assess things like
trust you see not surprisingly people
with out BPD have higher levels of
self-reported trust and the percentage
returned to the investor because of this
I think is higher and so the return to
the person with BPD who is struggling
with mistrust is also lower so the
ability to self enhance is limited by
this problem in trust now
there's been some work on the hormone
oxytocin because it stimulates social
bonding and there is some evidence that
it increases mental ization when you
squirt it up the nose so when you're
asking a spouse for a favor
little intranasal oxytocin can go a long
way
understand my position but if it only it
were that easy I think we wouldn't need
programs like the Gundersen residence
because there was another study done on
this to see if actually oxytocin helped
people with BPD to trust more and it
doesn't and actually make some defect
and collaborate less isn't that amazing
so there's something in the system so
this is an economic task you can read
about and I'm not going to belabor the
set up but what happens is that there
are differences between the healthy
controls and the people with BPD in
their expectations of what their partner
is going to do in the game and people
with BPD actually increase in trust with
oxytocin people with BPD decrease
significantly also in terms of response
to this cooperation tasks economically
people with out BPD increase their
cooperation with oxytocin people with
BPD decrease and it seems to be related
to attachment status actually and what
happens is for this kind of attachment
high anxiety and high avoidance that's
that double bind attachment preoccupied
but fearful when you administer oxytocin
cooperative behavior goes down okay and
this is the bind for family members of
people who have BPD when they get very
vulnerable they come to you but then
they push you away and it creates this
exhausting cycle that makes it hard for
you to keep up your mentalizing right
same for therapists and it's devastating
for the individual with BPD
because it only feeds into their
confusion and mistrust so there's a
different concept that is related to
this issue of trust and it's it has to
do with trust about information and how
you learn and generalize things whether
it's from psychotherapy or from
experience and this is something that I
have to say you know Pierre Vonnegut
just boggles my mind he has new ideas
all the time they sound extremely
elegant and then when I try to repeat
them it just like it's paralyzing so
I'll do my best so when it comes to
social learning there are a couple
things that we do to judge whether the
information is trustworthy you can judge
it based on the content you know you can
evaluate is that reasonably realistic
relevant to me and you can judge it
based on Authority now I'm a sucker for
peter fonda he whatever he says sounds
good to me but you know in children
really small children they actually
taken a lot of information about who to
trust and not to trust they've done very
elegant studies of children getting
information from people they know versus
people they don't know which is right
and wrong and they will recalibrate how
they respond to this information over
time they think a lot and so what helps
this process of learning is something
called extensive cues this is a signal
that helps a parent and child to have
joint attention on something and see it
as important and worthwhile and
generalizable okay so you see this
mother and child learning how to brush
teeth no so this includes like a kind of
eye contact a kind of way of speaking
and I think to say that attachment
really makes mentalizing go haywire
before I had kids I thought I would
never do baby talk but once I had kids
the things that came out of my mouth
were extraordinary and they have to do
with ostensive cues you see your baby
and you're like hi baby
doo doo doo doo boop boop and it's like
a kind of opening of the communication
highway okay if you go up to your child
and you're like because you're tired you
gave four talks a week they're not going
to kind of engage with you the same way
and take what you have to say as
seriously it won't be as emotionally
salient and there are some studies this
one is amazing and I can't say I
understand it completely but I'll try to
tell you what I understand about it
infants 18 months old they are able to
learn about this emotional expression of
a person non-verbally and they can
generalize it based on whether or not
they get this extensive cue this baby
hello
that makes a big difference that's why
we instinctually do that kind of stuff
so this is how it boils down it's in
your packet but basically what happens
is there are these two very strange
objects that a baby will not be familiar
with and there's a very nice research
assistant and she has an extensive queue
here and she smiles at one of the
objects and she like makes a bad smell
face to the other one and this 18 month
old doesn't have much vocabulary will
give somebody else the right object 70%
of the time is that amazing
who said babies can't mentalize but you
take the same person and make them
non-communicative
okay and this is what we can appreciate
about the fragility of attachment some
days I'm like this after a long day of
work you're tired okay you're not
attending and you express the same thing
and the percentage of producing the same
object for a different person drops
significantly without that extensive cue
isn't that amazing but if you actually
have the same person without the sense
of cue come back for the object the
percentage of giving the right object
goes up so babies can make this person
specific inference about what somebody
likes better or what's better
they only generalize that to another
person if there's an extensive cue if
there's a welcoming attitude and I think
this has something to do with why the
treatments for BPD work it allows the
clinicians who employ the treatments to
maintain the capacity for a sense of
queues okay gives them organization
support understanding of that patient to
really support their ability to provide
those extensive views
so how MBT therapy works based on this
really new research it just came out
it's really conceptualizing BPD as a
problem of trust these are smart people
some of the smartest people I ever met
came to my program and they still can't
function on basic level it's not an
intelligence problem but it's a problem
of trust and
earning okay without new learning
there's no change and when you have a
pet epistemic mistress you trust what's
in your mind your trust you mistrust
what's in your mind and you mistrust the
information presented to you because
yours too just stressed too in pain
there's a problem of generalizing any
information to find solutions to
problems that you have so therapy must
open a person's mind to social learning
through collaboration and a sense of
cues that's a kind of advance in
mentalization based theory and I think
this angelic face of auntie Bateman
helps they're really wonderful people I
think that's part of why their treatment
works so this is a kind of
reconsideration that applies to a lot of
things not just BPD this is for
educational achievement basically
attachment security it's just a bedrock
to a lot of things it helps you develop
social cognition understanding others
and social interactions understanding
how you should behave and how you behave
impact others that in turn affect
self-regulation both attentional
problems that is why so many people with
BPD have ADHD or something that looks
like it and it also causes problems of
impulsivity down here it affects
interpersonal functioning of course and
both the way that they interact with
systems that will become problematic and
use support systems and kind of get some
self esteem from the relationships there
is and this is kind of tied together
with this ability to keep the
information highway alive okay to think
to evaluate to let information in and
then generalize it to different contexts
all right so there are other advances in
MBT treatment that has to do with the
measurement of MBT mentalizing which
John alluded to there was this kind of
primary approach that had to do with
coding these information ease interviews
about attachment I myself that was the
first thing I did after graduating from
residency is fly to London and learn how
to do the AAI and it's incredibly
arduous it's a very time-consuming
resource intensive tool and while it's
very elegant its limited and so when I
started my postdoc I was really
interested in how do you measure this
thing and in the last 10 years there's
been enormous advance partly because the
Germans have so much money but basically
the first stab at this was looking at
the eyes and what they convey and so
this is the mind in the eyes test that
was kind of first used in trying to help
people to help differentiate people from
with autism from people without so this
is your test how autistic or not
autistic are you this is hard okay so
what do you think this is oh good job
okay how about this one this one's
harder sure about something okay good
good nothing too embarrassing there now
the problem is that when they try to see
if there are differences between BPD and
people without BPD in this kind of test
what they found was surprising so who do
you think's white there the BPD subjects
they do better on this test this is from
Eric Furtick who works with John so I
think the real reason that clinicians
don't want to work with patients with
BPD has nothing to do with their
difficulties or entreat ability but how
super in tune they are with reading the
therapist mine
the other day a patient came in the
office as trying to like dial a number
for her parents and she's like are you
mad at me and I'm like no yes she knew I
was mad at her before I knew I was mad
at her okay so there are updates now
there are better tools and this is a
movie that was created by some
researchers in Berlin it's an amazing
movie but it takes so long for research
to make it to the mainstream that you'll
see that the kind of personas are like
from the 80s or something but this is
how it works so there are these movie
clips they're incredibly cheesy but
they're very useful so this is cliff in
Sandra she's having a dinner party they
seem to enjoy themselves when cliff is
talking about his vacation to Sweden but
then Michael arrives he seems to be a
narcissist he dominates the conversation
directing his speech at Sandra alone
slightly annoyed by Michaels bragging
stories son Sandra shortly looks in
Cliff's direction and then asked Michael
tell me have you ever been to Sweden
what's going on here now this is your
pop quiz
you're a chance to show that you're not
autistic
why is Sandra asking us one to see if
Michael has something interesting to say
to to change the topic so cliff can
become involved in the conversation
three people actually give these answers
and four to bond with cliff because they
both seem to like to now they actually
use this to test people with BPD versus
people without and the amazing thing
about this is mind in the eyes didn't
necessarily differentiating
differentiate high-functioning autism
from normals but did autism normals and
with BPD I showed you that BPD people
are actually better at doing this but
with this particular assessment it did
differentiate people from with BPD from
those without and you see here is that
people with BPD they actually didn't
have differences with the healthy people
in reading the eye the mind and eyes but
they did on these mask scores amazing
and what happened before I move on is
that they also saw that people with BPD
with trauma did worse than the other two
groups so there's a role of trauma in
the ability to kind of Intuit what's
going on and more complex dynamic
interaction interpersonally now there's
also really interesting research that
comes out of Baylor with Carla Sharpe
who I think as an amazing mind and does
really interesting research she has
worked on an impatient adolescent unit
have found that hyper mentalizing this
kind of excessive thinking about what's
going on with people and complex
elaborate assumptions about what they're
thinking is correlated with BPD traits
and this actually explains something
about what has been called borderline
empathy okay
so borderline empathy was a term that
was introduced like pretty early on I
think 80s 90s and there were a bunch of
researchers who did some early research
on this interpersonal social cognitive
phenomenon with people with BPD and what
they found is that people with BPD had
greater levels of nonverbal sensitivity
to what was going on to other people and
also better ability to rate the motions
in other
and what was funny about this one study
by done by lattice shifts and that fail
I probably pronounce the names wrong is
they they raided people's ability to
understand other group members emotions
and the people who PPD did as well as
the psychiatrist's that's why group
therapy works for people with BPD
they're so good at helping each other
now but there's something more subtle
that happens is that people with BPD are
really good at the kind of cognitive
behavioral II driven like kind of
explicit domains but less skilled in
understanding what's happening inside
where there's no evidence for it and
where it has to do with emotions and the
problem is more a lack of balancing
between these two modes then that it's
completely absent okay and that hyper
mentalizing seems to be mediated the
relationship between hyper mentalizing
and BPD is mediated by emotional
dysregulation so there's a role of
emotional dysregulation which is a core
problem and be BPD per DB T and this
interpersonal kind of representational
disturbance so this is a complex model
of how we put all that we know about
social cognition BPD together that there
is a person with BPD as a receiver of
signals that is how they understand
what's going on with others they're
impaired or unstable capacity for
emotional empathy which is decreased by
childhood trauma and PTSD and challenged
by levels of high arousal and then there
are is BPD as the sender of social
signals that this is really interesting
people with BPD although they're known
for a lot of emotional intensity and
outward displays of anger and
helplessness
they actually have reduced facial
activity during some interpersonal
interactions which makes it harder for
other people to understand what's going
on with them and this relates to some of
the symptoms that we try to treat in
these disorders and I think this side of
it the reduce facial activity is
underappreciated because a lot of people
think about the crisis generating
behaviors or the acting out behaviors
whatever terminology you want to use but
you know what I find is that
families really relate to this the new
Smiley's I'm seconds away from bursting
into tears same face I'm actually
incredibly angry same face you will
never ever know how I really feel okay
and this might be due to the work of the
half smile maybe maybe it's marshes full
okay so with treatment outcomes there
are also advances so I'm not going to
belabor this but these are the original
studies that show that MBT work better
then treatment as usual okay that's what
that's what the early studies looked
like looked at is that comparison is
that it decreases suicidal and self
harming to be acts depressive symptoms
use of really intensive and expensive
public health resources and it does
increase social and interpersonal
functioning but not really that robustly
and it actually is not a cost issue MBT
might seem financially resource heavy at
the front end but it turns out to be a
savings in terms of intensive
psychiatric services MBT has the longest
course of follow-up this study was
looked at at eight years and the MBT
groups maintained their gains and
actually continue to get better after
treatment ended this has been replicated
by other groups and has been done in
outpatient and adolescent settings now
this I think is really the important
part is that I think we're at a point in
the development of these treatments to
let go of our territory
toriel kind of natures and get into this
horse race about what's better that's
not useful to really serve the public
and the people who need these treatments
we have to scale treatments to make them
generally available and give them more
intensive treatments to the people who
are more complicated okay not just to
the people who can afford them so this
is a study that was done on NB T now
this has to do with a number of axis won
and access to diagnosis and the thing
that I want to point your attention to
is that at 18 months this is justice in
well informed structured clinical
management of BPD that is just general
psychiatrists who really understand BPD
trying to manage the problem
and at 18 months compared to MBT MBT who
does better because it focuses on
personality disorders then just you know
like structure of clinical management
when it comes to the comorbidity with
access to on disorders but when it comes
to comorbidity with other personality
disorders when you just have BPD the
outcomes are decently comparable between
a structured clinical management and MBT
so when people just have BPD they might
really do well first with the general
psychiatric management approach and it's
when they have three or four personality
disorder features that these splits get
more progressive okay this is just a
graphical kind of representation this is
at one personality disorder they're not
that different but at four three or four
they become really divergent now this is
the end I think I made it so new
directions for treatment I think one of
the primary things that people Peter and
Anthony are trying to work on is
treatment of antisocial personality
disorder it's a really significant
public health concern
many people believe antisocial
personality disorder is untreatable like
borderline personality disorder was once
thought to be and they're trying to
design this program their program and
MBT to help patients who were prisoners
who have antisocial personality they're
trying to adapt this as general model
that you can adjust to people with
depression with or without BPD so with
BPD you have to actually monitor their
level of mentalizing and their
attachment activation and then go
through certain steps whereas people
with depression and not BPD you can do
without that part of it okay same other
components there's some trials going on
with eating disorders in BPD and like I
just presented NBT may turn out to be
superior from the most complex
presentations so to end I'm just going
to speak to some strengths and
weaknesses of this model no treatment is
a cure-all and I think really kind of
blind following of
one treatment as the best and others has
really devalued is really not that
helpful to the community or patients
that it treats but trying to have a
flexible view of what works in each
treatment is I think optimal and the
strengths of MVT is that it's a
generalizable model of psychotherapy
because these days because of
evidence-based medicine people are
pitching single treatments to single
disorders when patients actually usually
have more than one okay and what this
does is really pictured at a basic
process of psycho the psychotherapy that
is trying to help people think about
themselves in others and trying to
strengthen and stabilize that capacity
as the basis of any treatment so that
they can take in new information this
has been tested actually in a public
health context it's not in a rarefied
setting with just experts it's in a
public health context and it has this
kind of balance between integrating
traditional psychoanalytic ideas with
modern evolving or scientific findings
but there are certainly limitations we
run trainings for MBT at McLean it costs
a lot of money as does DBT training as
diss GFP training and it involves a lot
of dedication learning and supervision
by its practitioners and that's not
practical for everybody it's helpful for
advancing our understanding of these
treatments but might not be helpful for
dissemination of these treatments they
occur in specialist contexts they are
simple on the surface but but MBT is
simple on the surface but complex and
practice you actually have to just be a
good therapist to pull off any of these
treatments really well and you also need
the therapists have a robust capacity
for attachment and mentalization so this
is how you can reach me or my right-hand
person Anna Rodriguez via about more
learning about what we do teach in our
BPD Training Institute and I thank you
for your attention
thank you very much we have some
excellent questions we'll try to get a
couple in before the break there are a
couple of questions speaking to either
basically what we might call stepped
care models for people in the audience
that aren't familiar with them it's
where you might start with one treatment
and see how that works then go to
another one if it's not working or
potentially integrating or having
different courses of the treatments so
can MBT and DBT be integrated or it has
any work been done with DBT skills
training with MBT based individual
therapy that question was planted from
OPR for the Gundersen residents actually
we do combine these treatments of the
Gundersen residents and basically what
we do is a kind of culture and core of
DBT because the beauty of DBT is
prepackaged it's there
the counselors can learn the team can
communicate over a shared knowledge base
and set of skills and it just makes the
treatment more cohesive but the problem
is it doesn't breed a lot of Spontini
spontaneity of thinking there can be
like an over rigid education of the
skills so there's this like blind
application of skills without an
understanding what the problem is for a
person or the interpersonal problem that
prompted the set of distressing
effective behavioral responses that
occur so we balance this with MVT now I
don't actually advise that people
necessarily do that because it takes
incredible amounts of team communication
and rigorous formulation to make the
pieces of this actually make clinical
sense but if you have a set up work you
can be thoughtful and talk a lot with
your team I think it can work and
enhance the different aspects of both
agreed so in working with children or
families and chronic social or
environmental stress what challenges
might affect the implementation of MBT
for example can you potentially
mentalize when you're in a situation of
chronic stress or adversity and how
might that be addressed injury
you know this is where I do think this
kind of stepwise approach does health is
that whether it's a child in a chronicle
a stressful situation or a person with
BPD who's stuck in stage one like lots
of crises behavioral dysregulation there
has too many problems to think about
themselves you know they're just dealing
with one fire after another so sometimes
you do have to get into either a
situational change or a period of giving
them more skills to call all that down
so that they can think when you have too
many things going on in front of you you
can't think whether you have BPD or not
so I think one intervention is to really
reduce that level of stress by a
combination of environmental changes and
by supporting some skills to help the
families to also have what I think is
the number one intervention that
residential treatment accomplishes which
is family ectomy okay so that the
families and the patients can separate
and reconstitute their ability to think
because they get in such stressful
situations that they cannot think and
they're just reacting to each other so
sometimes these situational changes can
facilitate the ability to help someone
mentalize more and actually a lot of
people who come from the Manhattan area
in particular after they do our
treatment we send them to TFP because
they're more functional they're more
able to think about themselves they're
more able to kind of evaluate the
interactions that happen on the fly in
relationships so I do think there is
like an argument for a stage why
four-wide wise approach yeah there's
actually one of the questions we had was
do you think it's possible to have a
pyramid where you start with DBT and get
essential skills move on to MBT to learn
to mentalize and then go to d TFP that's
we might do but that costs a lot of
money
I don't actually necessary and at the
APA I gave it a presentation on
co-occurring personality disorders
things like NPD a SPD with BPD
and you know what happens is in a
program like ours where we have the
wealth of resources to try different
things more of good things don't
necessarily make people better it's
really understanding the patient at hand
and trying to figure out how much they
can use therapy and how much they need
to just build a life to get some
self-esteem to regulate their behavior
their ways of using time to structure
their relationships so for some patients
who don't respond to treatment I
actually advocate for like a get a life
track and support and getting a life I
think too many treatments remove people
from life and then you let them out and
they've got nothing going so how are
they gonna actually cope so I think
that's actually a problem to this kind
of we do this thing called like what
I've called in this recent book that
we've done a mood disorders and
borderline personality is premature
diagnostic certainty with therapeutic
overkill so if you have a person that
looks maybe bipolar or borderline they
go down these really exclusive paths of
getting really toxic medication regimens
and they might not even have bipolar
disorder or getting heavy amounts of
psychotherapy when they have something
that needs to be biologically treated so
keeping a flexible and open state of
mind about what are the specific
problems not just the diagnosis I think
will help us all do better treatment
we're out of time there's some excellent
questions so we'll save them for the
panel discussion but thank you very much